the raging debate economically that my
wife and i have is i always say you know
do we really need
another marketing major you know going
to school taking on debt and just coming
out with no expertise don't we need more
computer scientists and engineers and
people um
well the market already sort of sets a
price because you're graduating salary
if you were going into nuclear
engineering or you were going into
um hardcore material science or you were
going into crispr
for biotech you know would be much
higher than if you were coming out with
like just a liberal arts degree or some
you know marketing degree
and so you're already sort of a subprime
credit if you're pursuing the latter
and so i've made the argument why not
lend just like we used to you know
during the last uh housing crisis there
was prime credits based on
you know your likelihood to pay and
subprime credits why not based on the
major that you're electing to choose
to pursue have lower borrowing rates
so you might be a better credit if you
were pursuing computer science over the
past 10 years and you should borrow one
or two percent well
that would lower the cost of access of
capital it would increase the number of
people that were potentially applying
for it
and over time it would end up increasing
the supply of labor which would then
bring down the price and wages
in the marketplace and so you'd have a
natural sort of you know filtering
function
just letting the market based on
salaries dictate
where there was need you know five years
ago four years ago
insane demand for artificial
intelligence researchers you know people
that come out of the nuclear winter and
deep learning and convolution
convolutional neural nets were suddenly
the hottest in demand
and somebody that was making 50 000 or
less as a postdoc
was suddenly being offered half a
million to a million dollars at google
and facebook and
and so that was just insane and it
created a scarcity of labor
which was a signal to the market and now
you know every computer science program
is like you know flooding the zone with
with future ai researchers at a time
when it will probably bring down
all the wages and then you know the next
area that's totally scarce will become
you know the hot demand same thing in an
area you know where you're an expert in
crypto right there's
anytime there's this sort of information
arbitrage and ignorance
and that's reflected in the prices of
wages
of labor um i think it's a signal and so
if you want to redirect
where useful resources of humanity goes
you know prices today are still the best
way that we have to signal that to the
masses